d'une manière générale au delà de
soixante huit mois je suis spécialiste
des crises en quelque sorte j'ai vu les
ravages de la guerre j'ai vu ce que ça
représente
y compris la guerre civile dans certains
pays donc je souhaite éviter ça c'est
les militaires nous on a une
caractéristique c'est que la guerre on
n'en parle pas on l'a fait on l'a fait
on en connaît les ravages et on ne
connaît les atrocités et cette haine qui
monte cette violence verbale qui précède
la violence physique qui ne cesse de se
développer
moi je peux pas laisser faire ça sans
rien dire ayant connu ça dans d'autres
pays
après ce que j'ai retenu de 70 de 2,68
c'est cet équilibre nécessaire entre
parfois des contraires avec eux
7 cette ligne de crête sur lequel il
faut être parfois avec deux plateaux
puisque équilibre ça veut dire deux
balances
aujourd'hui on n'est pas assez ferme et
on n'est pas assez humain il n'y a pas
assez de respect il n'y a pas assez
d'exigence ya pas assez de bienveillance
ya pas assez de fermeté
voilà ce que je pense et c'est cet
équilibre que j'essaie de décrire dans
mon livre pour éviter que l'on ne
bascule dans des temps beaucoup plus
difficile encore
[Musique]